[Music]
the 1990s were a golden age of
television animation
but cartoons are a business and even the
most beloved shows are sometimes
cancelled
to make room for more profitable
programming here's the real reason these
90s cartoons were canceled
in the 1990s fox became the only place
on broadcast tv where primetime
animation could find an audience
and flourish creatively following the
success of the simpsons
the network debuted another very
different show about a cartoon family in
early 1997
king of the hill created by beavis and
butthead mastermind mike judge
the low-key but hilarious series
centered on hank hill
an extremely uptight family man from the
town of arlen texas
who loved beer football and selling
propane he often struggled to relate to
his weird tween son bobby
teaching my boy the facts of life is my
job
right king of the hill earned all kinds
of emmy attention
and was a consistent hit with viewers it
remained on the fox lineup for well over
a decade
but after 259 episodes king of the hill
was out of gas
its final episode to sirloin with love
aired just before the start of the
2009-2010 tv season king of the hill
helped further popularize network
cartoons but ironically
the show was forced to step aside for a
new animated series
shortly after fox announced its final
order of king of the hill episodes
it gave a full season pick up to the
cleveland show
a spin-off of the hit cartoon family guy
before a slew of blockbuster x-men
movies hit the silver screen
kids got to know professor xavier's crew
of super-powered mutants on fox's
saturday morning staple x-men
the animated series based on the marvel
comics that date back to the 60s
the show was mostly serialized with
viewers required to turn in each week to
see how multi-part story lines played
out
x-men the animated series debuted on fox
in 1992
and eventually moved to its weekend
morning time slot where it aired until
1997.
that's a bit longer than the network or
producers had envisioned
the show was only supposed to run 65
episodes
a standard production run for an
animated show in the 90s
fox ultimately wanted a total of 76
episodes
and once those 76 episodes were finished
so was x-men
the animated series i miss you
i never knew how much i would we all
miss
scott the question is how will we move
on without her
doug premiered in 1991 and was one of
the sweetest
gentlest cartoons of its era it was told
from the point of view of awkward tween
doug funny
who makes up for his painful shyness
with a wildly active fantasy life
this wasn't so hard maybe if i kept at
it
nickelodeon ended production on doug in
1994.
shortly after that disney purchased abc
and launched the one saturday morning
programming block
according to doug creator jim jenkins
disney aggressively pursued his
animation studio jumbo pictures
because it wanted doug in slimed and
oral history of nickelodeon's golden age
jenkins asked
so should i stay with nickelodeon who is
through with me
or get bought by disney where we get to
create 65 new half hours of dug
a feature-length movie dug live for
their theme park
toys books additional funding for
development and production on many new
series
in 1996 brand spanking new doug hit abc
more focused on the business side of
doug jenkins wasn't around to maintain
quality and the show arguably went
downhill when others stepped in
casting director wendy litwack said doug
suffered when it changed to disney
because of network intervention
the new doug came to a conclusion at the
end of its third season
followed by a big screen movie
hey arnold joined the nicktoons lineup
in 1996
and quickly became one of nickelodeon's
most popular and enduring
shows for five seasons fans eagerly
tuned in
to watch the many adventures of this
group of highly independent city kids
steel mill weird the steel mill sure
why'd you think it worked this train
isn't haunted
in 1998 nickelodeon renewed hey arnold
and ordered a feature film
which creator greg bartlett began
working on after the fifth season
it was a straight to video project
called arnold saves the neighborhood
but it was also released to theaters as
hey arnold the movie
the movie flopped in 2002 earning only
13 million dollars at the american box
office that marked the end of hey arnold
in any form
until bartlett returned to nickelodeon
to produce hey arnold the jungle movie
in 2016.
roseanne barr ruled abc in the late 80s
and early 90s
roseanne the sitcom based on her
stand-up comedy act
finished the 1989-90 season as the
number one show on network tv
in the fall of 1990 the network tried to
capitalize on her popularity with a
roseanne barr show just for kids
a saturday morning cartoon called little
rosie
little rosie revolved around an
eight-year-old version of barr
nobody from the roseanne sitcom voiced
their animated kitty counterparts not
even barr
abc tried to interfere with the
production early on requesting that
rosie's friend group include more boys
it was reportedly a difficult show to
make and ratings weren't so great
no wonder little rosie only lasted one
season mrs canker
i won't get it on sorry i kicked the
ball into your yard
we don't do it on purpose and we don't
like to bother
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]